the Philippines has summoned beijing's
Ambassador over two collisions between
Philippine and Chinese vessels in the
South China Sea the countries have
blamed each other for the incidents on
Sunday they were between a Chinese ship
and a Filipino vessel that was supplying
troops on an outpost in disputed Waters
barab low is in Manila with the
latest the Philippines and China blaming
each other for collisions that happened
in the South China Sea on Sunday morning
the Philippines saying it was dangerous
maneuver by Chinese vessels trying to
block the path of Philippine vessels on
the way to the second Thomas sh carrying
Provisions for Filipino troops station
there that caused these collisions
continued Chinese blocking and
interference by Chinese vessels with our
regular and routine rotation and
resupply missions R to BRP sheram Madre
may lead to disastrous results China
meanwhile saying a Philippine supply
boat cut up across the bow of one of its
Coast Guard vessels and a Philippine
supply boat reversing hitting one of its
Maritime militia
vessels the actions of the Philippine
side seriously violated International
Maritime collision avoidance rules
threatening the navigation safety of our
vessels now tensions have been running
High between Manila and Beijing for
almost the entire year over this
territorial dispute in the South China
Sea in February Chinese Sailors directed
military grade laser against their
Filipino counterparts and months later
they used water cannon China of course
lays claim over almost the entire South
China Sea but this particular area where
the collisions took place is 200 kilm
from the westernmost province of the
Philippines and so Manila insists that
it has Sovereign rights over this area
of the South China Sea Barn below alzer
Manila